Now, gross profit amounts to your total
revenue minus your cost of goods sold.
So that's answer B.
Cost of goods sold may
also be a new term for
you and this refers to the costs
associated with making your product.
For example, say your business
is selling water bottles,
and this is a water bottle, I promise.
Now, you sell these water bottles for
$19.99.
But it costs you $5.60 to make them.
Your cost of goods sold is then this
$5.60 and when you subtract that from
your total revenue per water bottle,
you get a remainder of $14.39.
Also known as your gross
profit per water bottle.
Net profit is then your total
revenue after subtracting
all of your expenses as
an operating business.
Now, keep in mind that this
can easily be a net loss.
And your goal is to implement
a monetization model that
keeps your numbers positive.